daddy do you know why you're here
I have spring spots
[Music]
sometimes I think that night
that night everything that came
afterwards
[Music]
couldn't be a coincidence could it
brought in a kid last night might be
something that interests me daddy you
don't really seem like a dangerous
person
[Music]
how you ended up here
loser hey I'm gonna kick your little
wiry ass
[Music]
thank you
go you want to come here clean yourself
up
you are safe now you never struck you as
strange
that this man
figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky
no
there's blasts everywhere signs of a
struggle Blood on the floor
what about the girl what sign of her
either I'm thinking any officer [__] did
you do this wasn't a random shooting
he's hiding something
what happened in that house where did
they all go
they're not the only people close to you
to disappear are they
I think these were all victims
[Music]
see how all of this can seem like it was
you wait do you think that I'm the one
pulling the strings
what if I said I do I'm not
Danny I'm trying to help you help you I
didn't
choose the best interest is to plead
guilty they're all in this together if
I'm right Danny may be innocent what are
you not telling me
what are you not telling yourself